هي ضربه موجعه لكيف في خضم حربها مع موسكو
وزير الداخليه الاوكراني ومساعده الاول
ومسؤولون كبار قضوا في تحطم طائره مروحيه
شمال شرقيات لا تفاصيل عن سبب الحادثه الى
حينه لكن الرئاسه الاوكرانيه قالت ان
المروحيه تحطمت وهي في طريقها الى احدى
النقاط الساخنه حيث تدور المعارك بهذا
يكون وزير الداخليه الاوكراني المسؤول
الاوكراني لارفع مستوانا الذي يلقى حذفه
منذ سنه روسيا حربها على اوكرانيا قبل نحو
عامه
الكبيره في ما قال رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني
انه اصدر تعليمات بتشكيل فريق خاص على
الفور لاجراء تحقيق مفصل في كافه ملابسات
الماسات على حد وصفهه وكتب حاكم منطقه
الثياب ان هناك ضحايا واصابات منهم اطفال
وموظفون في روضه اطفال في بلده بروفيري
حيث المروحيه فيما نقلت رويترز عن شهود
عيان قولهم ان الجو كان معتما وضبابيا وقت
وقوع الحادثه وان المروحيه اصابت روضه
اطفال قبل ان تتحطم بالقرب من مبنى سكني